[Música]
el primer teléfono celular de la
historia fue visto por primera vez en el
año 1983 pesaba 800 gramos
aproximadamente obvio estaban dijo horas
para poder cargarlo y sólo se podía
hablar por 30 minutos cuánta diferencia
hay con los celulares de ahora verdad el
mío por ejemplo pesa 150 gramos
aproximadamente obvio estoy dos horas
como mucho para poder cargarlo y me dura
todo el día dependiendo qué tanto lo use
y puedo hablar con quien yo quiera el
tiempo que yo quiera y desde donde sea
los celulares nos ayudan a resolver
muchos de los problemas que podamos
llegar a tener porque lo digo porque si
no sabemos cómo ir a algún lugar haremos
google maps porque podemos integrarnos
en las noticias que pasa en el mundo
vamos a ver el clima vamos sacar fotos y
mandarles en cuestión de segundos tienen
calculadora tienen reloj y pueden
acortar distancias pero a qué me refiero
con que pueden acortar distancias a que
podemos contactarnos con cualquier
persona sin importar el lugar donde
estemos sin embargo a veces no nos
podemos comunicar con las personas que
tenemos al lado debido que le prestamos
demasiada atención al celular
toque el timbre 15 minutos de recreo al
fin la profesora me estaba cansando
alguno de mis compañeros son de un curso
para despejarse y de la cantina comprar
algo de comer e ir al baño
carrero en sus botellas yo por otro lado
me quedo en el curso me agarró mi
celular entro a instagram para irse
archivo me gusta subir una historia o
capaz alguna página de ropa subiera una
foto entre whatsapp tengo mensajes sin
responder del grupo del cole pero de
todas formas entro a twitter para ver
las últimas cosas que se publicaron
toqué el timbre de nuevo 80 minutos
encerrados en el curso
el celular al ser más adictivo provoca
fobias y enfermedades al no tenerlo una
de ellas es la nomofobia que es la
abreviación en inglés de no mobile
phones fobia es el miedo a no estar
conectado el miedo de no tener celular
cerca uno de los factores más comunes
que presenta esta fobia están
relacionados a la inseguridad personal
esto refiere a la falta de seguridad en
cada uno y la baja autoestima
esta fobia se da en niños adolescentes y
adultos mayoritariamente en adolescentes
debido a que están más familiarizados
con las nuevas tecnologías llega a mi
casa del cole me siento en la mesa está
mi hermana y mi mamá pero de todas
formas agarro mi celular y me pongo a
responder los mensajes que no respondía
antes
/ instagram para ser bien historias
terminó de comer y me voy a mi pieza
díganme no les pasa cuando están en
juntas con amigos almuerzos familiares o
salidas que están todo el tiempo con sus
celulares y no están hablando o
interactuando con las personas que
tienen su alrededor a mí me pasa todo el
tiempo pasamos horas y horas frente al
celular sin que importe nada de lo que
está a nuestro rededor y me paso por el
día del amigo nos juntamos todos o mejor
dicho casi todos mis amigos en total son
un grupo de 12 y créanme es muy difícil
poder coordinar horarios para vernos ya
que algunos entrenan tienen facultad o
trabajan pero seguía pudimos estar la
mayoría juntos aunque después de comer
era muy fácil notar
cada uno estaba en su mundo con su
celular mis amigos se pasaron la mayor
parte del tiempo cuando un juego en
línea de sus celulares estaban hablando
e interactuando entre ellos mediante su
celular empiezas solo frente a frente
cuando estaban sentados al lado que
increíble no no nos vemos nunca y cuando
nos vemos estamos para no estar cada uno
conectado con su celular conectado
virtualmente para alejarse de lo que
tiene al lado
y lo peor
es que cada uno está en la misma y nadie
espera más del otro que eso
le voy a contar elementos sobre un texto
que lea y
lo escribo agostina pini y se titula
porque ahora no lloras porque ahora
pones emoticón triste ella cuenta
brevemente cómo es tu día a día se
levanta desayuna vale faculta en
colectivo y vuelve esta educación
colectiva cuenta como su trayecto cuenta
como ella observa los paisajes los
pasajeros a los ancianos las embarazadas
los niños ella observa todo a su
alrededor pero un día volviendo a su
casa
decidió mirar por la ventana al
colectivo de al lado que había tenido
que frenar por un semáforo en rojo que
observó que todas las personas en el
colectivo estaban en la misma posición
cada una en su mundo con su celular y
nadie estaba observando todo a su
alrededor como ellos siempre lo hacía
y me dejó pensando si metido en el
celular dejamos de mirar lo que nos
rodea
y si me tiene celular dejamos de hablar
o interactuar con los que tenemos al
lado
donde queramos nosotros
que nosotros queda destilado terminamos
desapareciendo detrás de una pantalla y
tenemos que darnos cuenta es de regular
y las cosas que tiene celular va a estar
presentes por mucho tiempo las personas
que están al lado nuestro no nuestros
amigos nuestros padres hermanos todas
las personas alrededor nuestro no son
eternas lamentablemente y ojo nosotros
tampoco dejemos el lado un rato del
celular y démonos cuenta de la cantidad
de cosas que nos estamos perdiendo por
algo tan insignificante y material como
celular te propongo algo cuando esté con
tu amigos deja al ser uno al lado rey te
ponemos a contar chistes cuenten viejas
anécdotas que tengan rían sea ésta que
les duele la panza lo mismo con su
familia pregunte no es cómo fue su día
cuéntales cómo fue el de ustedes
pónganse a contar viejas historias
también pero dejen de sembrar un lado
porque no les digo que dejen ese lugar
cuando están aburridos en su casa porque
quien lo quiere ver un capítulo de
netflix de cualquier serie les estoy
diciendo que dejen su celular cuando
están con alguien porque el problema es
que creemos que tenemos tiempo que lo
que no podemos hacer hoy lo podemos
hacer mañana pero la vida es ahora
digamos momentos únicos que el tiempo
corre gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah